- [Instructor] My grandfather
often tries to persuade me
that he is still groovy
but how how groovy can be be
if he still uses the word groovy?
I actually like the
way that that's written
because they're saying my
grandfather often tries
to persuade me that he is still groovy
and that means kind of cool
for those of you who might be too young
to know what groovy means
bu that's a good point
but how groovy can he be
if he still uses this word groovy,
so I like that,
this but kind of, it's
kind of turning the tide
on the first part of the sentence
and that's why you would use a but
and so, I'm leaning towards no change
but let's feel good that we can rule out
the other choices.
My grandfather often tries to persuade me
that he still groovy
because how groovy can he be
if he still uses the word groovy?
Well, because implies that the
grandfather does this thing,
because of this thing,
so because of how groovy can he be,
that's the reason why
he tries to persuade him
or his grandfather or his grandson
that he's still groovy.
No, that doesn't make sense.
My grandfather often tries to persuade me
that he is still groovy
meaning how groovy can he be
if he still uses the word groovy.
No, that also doesn't make sense
because meaning would mean
that there's some type of
clarifying that is going
of the first part of the clause
and that's not what's going on here.
You actually have kind of a opposition
to the first clause, it's
kind of contradicting it
a little bit, it's like
how groovy can he be
if he still uses the word groovy?
And that's why but is a
really good thing there.
My grandfather often tries to persuade me
that he is still groovy
since how groovy can he be
if he still uses the word groovy?
So, once again, since kind
of draws a natural cause
and effect, since this, this is happening
but it isn't since how groovy he can be,
how groovy can he be
if still uses the word groovy.
That's not somehow causing him
to persuade his grandchild
that he's still groovy,
so this also doesn't feel right at all.
I really like this.
These two clauses are
kind of in opposition,
they're kind of contradicting it,
they don't contradict but
this second clause opposes
the first one in kind of a fond way,
it turns the tide back on it
by using the word groovy itself.
It's actually just a fun sentence.
So, we actually fill in the answer.
You don't wanna forget
filling in your answer.